Here, give an atemi.
Here, too, so we have 2 atemi on 2 levels.
At this point,
while you do this,
like this,
place his arm here; the technique is Hiji-Kujiki
In this case we do Han-tsuki [half tsuki used for training].
In reality, it is like this. Why is that? Because it hurts!
Then I went to Hokkaido,
but all these scrolls were written here in Shikoku.
They did not have them anywhere else, not even at Soke's [Takeda Tokimune] dojo.
Who had these scrolls originally?
[Takuma] Hisa Sensei had them,
Makita [Kan'ichi] had them too.
He showed them to Hisa Sensei who said:
"There are no mistakes so you can use them for the Takumakai"
Regarding the originals, there isn't much to say except that they are hard to understand.
The origin of the Aizu clan is written here.
This is the historic origin of the scrolls from Emperor Seiwa.
This is Shinra Saburo.
This is where it starts.
In Daito-ryu, we often relate the beginings to Shinra Saburo but things actually start earlier.
The history?
Yes, we start from Shinra Saburo, however, we can see here that it actually starts before him.
Nobody speaks about that usually.
Where is Takeda Sokaku?
There, "Takeda Sokaku",
and "Uemon",
this is Takeda Sokaku's father.
Here it is written "Sokaku",
"Daito-ryu".
Is this Takeda Sokaku here?
No, this is Takeda Kuninyoshi,
and so on...
When does it actually start then?
It is difficult to know precisely.
We should start looking around the Emperor Seiwa and go back through the generations
These are the 36 kajo.
Here I don't understand [old writing].
Here are some of the techniques.
But I can't even read these old characters.
This is the Aizu language.
You don't understand it?
It is like a local style of speech, like the one in Kansai, Kanto, Tohoku, etc.
What if we went to Aizu?
Yes, Aizu in the Fukushima prefecture.
There is a group there, but there is also the sanctuary of Shinra Saburo!
Before, we never showed these scrolls to anybody.
We unrolled them during practice and put them away straight after.
Nowadays in Wakimachi, the scrolls are carved in wood, So anyone who enters the dojo can see them.
I gave three atemi, did you see?
From there, you can enter like this.
And that [hand] is well secured.
Therefore you can go there.
Don't collapse like that!
And then, same [as before].
Lock it using your small finger.
If you lock with your small finger, the base of the thumb becomes weak, so it is easier.
On this kind of grab,
strike with atemi from the bottom to the top, up to the chin.
And a 2nd one on the side,
No! Not on the keikogi!
On the right elbow! On the joint.
With the leg too, all at the same time.
Then you grab here and you turn your shoulders
Then, with your fist [not grabbing], lift my elbow up
Now grab!
How long ago [did you go to Hokkaido] Sensei?
I forgot!
How old were you?
About 20 years old.
So it was about 60 years ago.
It is Makita Sensei who took me there.
There was me, Makita, and 2 or 3 other students.
We were 4 or 5 altogether.
Did Chiba Sensei ever meet Takeda Sokaku Sensei?
No, the generations were different.
The one who taught me was Takeda Tokimune Sensei.
At the time he was the director of the Yamada Suisan company.
He taught in the city of Abashiri [in Hokkaido].
Takeda Sensei's way of teaching was: "Do shikko" [movements on the knees]
There were about 30 or 50 tatami in the Daito-kan  [Tokimune's dojo].
So I did shikko.
He was watching carefully.
You had better not get it wrong otherwise...
But in fact, he was nice.
Before, he had been a policeman
and one day he broke the hand of a thief.
He felt responsible and left the police.
He then went to the Yamada Suisan where he had family.
There was no Takumakai at the time right?
No, not yet.
It was the time of the Kansai Aikido Club.
In Shikoku too, was it the same?
In Shikoku, I was the teacher.
It was called Daito-ryu Aiki-budo wasn't it?
Yes, that's right, Daito-ryu Aiki-budo.
Takeda Tokimune was also doing Aiki-budo.
There was no Takumakai.
Over there, at the Daito-kan,
we had to sign an admission form to be allowed to learn.
It was the first time that we learned techniques up to 5th kajo.
Before that, we only got to 2nd kajo.
What kind of keiko were we doing at Tokimune's dojo?
We used to do shikko
and work on katatedori, ryotedori
and also some katame waza.
This is what we used to do, what we call warm-up these days.
Over there, they used to grab like that, it was very different from the way we used to do it.
Exercises on joints by controlling the wrists.
We used to grab directly, flat like that.
But over there, they first took hold from the small finger.
So the hand that was being grabbed could not open up.
It could not use any strength.
We used to work like that, on controlling the wrists, we got control of the elbow.
From which finger do you start to grab?
From the small finger or from the thumb,
which one is the quickest?
From the small finger?
Yes, from the small finger, because it is the dumbest [less functional], and therefore the quickest.
Then there is the thumb, the thickest and most powerful.
It is with these two that you can have the best grab.
The other fingers don't matter.
This is important because if you do this...
look, with the thumb and the small finger together,
the thumb and the small finger close the grab.
Got it?
That is in Kote-jime, as well as other tecniques...
You can grab like this too
That is the way to do for women.
You must understand well the way to lock the hand.
This is already Gyaku-kote,
the Gyaku-kote of 2nd kajo, but it is exactly like the Kote-zume that we saw earlier on.
They are related techniques, Gyaku-kote here, and Kote-zume here.
We just finished the Saturday class.
We did 3 hours of Daito-ryu so we are quite tired.
We are going to have dinner now.
Before that we went to the public bath in the mountain near Wakimachi
After dinner we will go back to the dojo and take some photographs from Chiba Sensei's archives.
And tomorrow morning we are going to be back on the tatami
See you later and "bon appetit"!
Good job everybody!
I'll show you something that we never eat at home.
It is fresh bamboo, it is delicious.
It tastes a bit like heart of palm.
How come this Nihonshu has bubbles?
This is like Japanese Champagne.
Big bubbles!
It is not too sweet, it is perfectly balanced.
Very good isn't it?
That is what they made me do
as well as some grabs such as ryotedori.
They told me: "Come over here!"
I asked why and the answered:
"Because you don't do Ken [sword]".
Not like Kendo,
so that is when I started to work with a big log of wood,
as thick as a leg!
Big like this.
We also used metal bars or wood logs,
training in rhythm.
We used to strike like this to build up our muscle frame.
This is also what Tokimune Sensei used to do in the morning right?
Yes, all of it.
Chiba Sensei learned from watching Tokimune Sensei's morning classes.
This work is important isn't it?
Yes, especially this way of twisting.
It is not just about swinging like that.
You have to pinch like this and because the handle is so big, there is some remaining space that you cannot hold.
Like if you were waving a big pole.
So you have to synchronize the pinching of each hand to have them together.
You have to raise straight up.
Everybody ended up as massive as Suzuki Sensei.
Suzuki Sensei never lost, not even against Sumo or Judoka.
When he grabbed you, you couldn't move.
He would grab and the other guy went flying.
Soke Takeda started at 5 a.m. because he had to go to work at 6 a.m.
at the company Yamada Suisan.
Did you continue at the dojo after 6 a.m.?
He would stop a bit before 6 a.m. and we would go back to the nearby hotel.
We quickly took our breakfast over there
And then, Suzuki Sensei would teach us while doing some calligraphy on his own.
It lasted until lunchtime.
So about 6 h of training
until 12 a.m.
That is why we could learn all that, it never stopped!
All the classes, without a break.
The Sensei did not want to give us a break.
That is why the techniques got into our heads.
We couldn't even drink tea
even though we really felt like having some.
we had all our meals at the hotel, in the morning, lunch, and dinner.
In the evenings, Suzuki Sensei was teaching.
With Soke we only learnt until 2nd kajo
and when we finally managed to do 1st and 2nd kajo,
we asked Suzuki Sensei, showing him the board:
"We would like to also learn 3rd and 4th kajo, would it be possible?"
But he said that it was not possible because we weren't deshi.
However, he spoke to Tokimune and one day,
our names got written on the board as "Shikoku students"
Then he asked some deshi to start training with us too.
We started to train with the others on that night.
What is the purpose of atemi?
When he comes to grab, what is he going to do?
You can do this of course.
But there is also Yokomen
So if we do that, what is happening?
You can chose this hand, or that one.
You have to sort it out in your heads!
You must think of that one [the one delivering the atemi].
It leads us to the typical entry of Kurumadaoshi
This is a fundamental point of the [118 techniques] list.
It is that sort of reasoning that informed the making of that list.
This hand at the collar allows a hand strike but also a kick.
So on this side you do like this, and on that side, you do this.
On the joint!
By pushing on the joint, it straightens the arm.
Give it a good strike!
That makes 2 atemi, plus another one below in the legs.
This is how you teach these important points.
Now, how do you give this kick?
You kick with what is in front, the forward leg
And after that,
you see, while he kicks, he straightens his arm, so I am stronger than him now and he can no longer do it.
But if you go forward, the effect is greater.
This is 2nd kajo right?
Get a good hold, surround the wrist with your small finger,
and raise the elbow.
Lock it well, close the space.
We are done for the day,
we are dead tired so I wish you a good night.